[Music]
mariah carey is shaking off a texting
fail i have no idea i don't recognize
time with shawn mendes
yeah it's an interesting story let us
explain so mimi has a silly tradition
with her cousin who's also named sean m
in her phone where they wish each other
happy thanksgiving on st paddy's day
happy saint patty's day
but this year she texted the wrong sean
m i don't know what you mean
yeah the luck of the irish was not on
mariah's side when she realized the 23
year old singer shawn mendes was on the
receiving end of her inside joke
i'm doing the best i can the grammy
winner shared the hilarious text
exchange on social media after realizing
she wasn't texting with her cousin she
wrote wrong sean sorry also i do realize
it's not thanksgiving
the in my blood singer responds with a
laugh quote i figured it was an inside
joke it's really crazy but of course
this is mimi we're talking about the
queen of holidays and it's not the first
time she's been called out for
celebrating early like when et spoke
with her ahead of thanksgiving but she
was already in full-blown christmas mode
i know we're early kevin i'm not saying
we're not early we gotta get through
thanksgiving first and i know this but
when i started i made my first christmas
album and i was traveling the world and
i'm like wow they're really into
christmas early late because there's no
thanksgiving they don't have
thanksgiving
yep we know mariah lives for a holiday
moment
i'm festive i can't help it christmas
for for me
i wait for it all year long
i am the most festive person that i know
um i have
reindeer santa claus is my friend we see
him every year
of course she's channeled her passion
into countless tv specials albums and
songs
like this hit you know the one
[Music]
i love it it's part of my life i feel
like i grew up with it and share it with
the world for me christmas music i could
do it in my sleep because i love it that
much you know what i mean yes and we
thank you for it mariah thank you
darling
as for how the queen of christmas
celebrates snow lots and lots of snow if
them babies don't enjoy christmas i
don't know who does okay i spend the
whole year figuring it out
and you know look they do enjoy
christmas we ski they go i mean we ski
they ski i take one run down the
mountain and i'm good but they snowboard
they do everything we're all here we
have the best time of christmas we
really go
all the way in every christmas every
year and i just want my kids to have the
best time
and
honestly it's like a lot of it is for me
[Music]
you